Readers don't care about your ideas
because you're opening your text with
hooks instead of value. So, today I'm
going to show you what I learned after
analyzing over 100 introductions from
professional and academic genres. You're
going to learn three critical things
that every writer must have in their
introduction to make readers instantly
want to read the rest of the piece.
Whether it's a newsletter, white paper,
research report, sales page, or a book
proposal. This three-part pattern for
introductions is not just a list of
style tips. It's a powerful structure
that I've noticed in the most effective
and persuasive documents. It's designed
to create value for your readers. And
it's helped my clients get their
research funded, published, pitch
startups, and convert readers into
buyers. And by the way, if you're new
here, my name is William. I'm an English
professor at one of the top universities
in South Korea. And for 10 years, I've
been teaching writing from the reader
perspective. And to show you the number
one mistake that I notice in so many
non-fiction introductions, we're going
to take a look at a model essay by
George Mack about high agency. Here's
how he describes it. After 7 months of
writing, I finished my essay. I think
agency might be the most important idea
of the 21st century. So, to understand
what's wrong here, picture your reader
like somebody walking through a crowded
market with their arms full trying to
get home. Now imagine there are two
vendors calling out to them. The first
vendor says, "Step right up. I spent
nine months perfecting this amazing
product and I truly believe it's one of
the most important inventions of the
year." Vendor two says, "Need to carry
all that easier? This bag has reinforced
handles that won't rip." So which one
are they stopping for? Well, obviously
the second one because the first vendor
is talking about themselves, their
efforts, their beliefs, and their
product. The second vendor is talking
about the customer's problem and
offering them a solution. Most writers
are like vendor number one. Even the
good ones like George Mack. Working on
an essay for seven months and saying
that you think it's important does not
create value. So, to find out what does,
let's take a look at the introduction to
George Max's essay. Now, George didn't
ask me to edit this, and since the essay
got pretty popular on its own, I think
it's fair to say that he doesn't need my
help. But I chose this essay for three
reasons. First, it's got a good idea
that's worth spreading. Second, the
essay was relatively successful, so any
critiques I make aren't punching down,
they're punching up. And third, despite
the success of this essay, it's a
perfect example of the kind of writing
mistake that I see in so many
introductions. So, here's how George
opens. Warning, this is not doom
scrolling. It's an idea so simple yet
effective, it may change how you view
reality. It takes 30 minutes on average
to read. What is high agency? I believe
high agency might be the most important
idea of the 21st century. When I first
learned of High Agency, it felt like a
secret that had been hidden from me. So,
what is it? In a 1964 public inquiry
into whether the film The Lovers should
be banned for its adult content, Supreme
Court Judge Justice Potter Stewart was
asked to define pornography. He replied
with the ultimate non-defin, I know it
when I see it. High agencies is one of
those I know it when I see it ideas. And
once you see it, you can't unsee it. So
before I explain it, let's see it. So do
you see what's happening here? George
Mack is telling us that he thinks the
topic is important. He's telling us it
felt like a secret to him. But unless
you already care about what George Mack
thinks or you've already heard Eric
Weinstein talk about high agency first,
there's nothing in this text that makes
you care about high agency. This
introduction offers only a topic. it
doesn't motivate us to care about it.
So, the introduction fails to answer the
reader's number one question. So, what
readers don't read non-fiction for
entertainment. They read when they
perceive the text as valuable. And value
is not a function of whether the author
thinks that something is important.
Value is a function of problems and
their solutions. So, here is a
three-part introduction structure that
the most effective essays use to not
merely introduce a topic, but to
establish value. Value is a function of
problems. So, the job of the
introduction is to set up a problem.
But, slow down, Mr. Uncensored. It's not
time to just jump in off the top ropes
with your hot take. Think of it like
this. Imagine you're at a party and
someone walks up to you and immediately
says, "Everything you believe about
success is wrong." Well, your first
reaction is probably to be defensive,
maybe even annoyed. You're definitely
not going to say, "Oh, wow. Tell me
more." But what if instead that person
says, "You know how everyone says hard
work and patience lead to success?"
Well, that's true for a lot of people
and then they challenged it. That's a
totally different feeling. And that
difference is because they found common
ground first. They acknowledge something
that you already believe before asking
you to reconsider it. So, let's go back
to George Max's essay. He wants us to
adopt his idea of high agency, which is
people who take charge and make things
happen. But instead of diving straight
into here's what high agency is, watch
what happens if we start with something
that readers already accept. And that
would be many people sit back, wait for
orders, and don't take charge on their
own. a problem so pervasive in
workplaces that economists call it the
principal agent problem. Now, at this
point, you're probably nodding along,
like you've seen that behavior before,
and maybe you've even been that person
sometimes. So, you're comfortable. You
feel like the writer gets you. That's
the setup. That's your common ground.
And the beautiful part of opening this
way is that once you've got readers
nodding along, that's when you can flip
the script on them. You've lined up the
dominoes and now you can knock them
over. So before you challenge your
reader thinking, you need to establish
common ground that they already accept,
which is what I call establishing the
status quo. And here's how to do it in
three steps. First, it's a good idea to
invert your idea. So, whatever idea it
is that you're building towards, you
should think about the opposite of that
because that's going to be a really
powerful way to demonstrate the value.
Like, if you can get your reader nodding
along at the start of the essay and then
have the essay oriented toward exactly
the opposite of that, then your reader
is going to be given the feeling that
there's something about the world that
they don't understand. Second, you need
to think about what do your readers
already believe. Look for something that
they're not going to dispute, something
that seems totally obvious or widely
accepted. This is going to be your
shared context. And you can establish it
in three different ways. All right? So,
you can open with the historical
background. So, that could be something
like for decades taking initiative has
been key to professional success. Or you
could open with a recent event such as a
recent survey showed 70% of employees
feel stuck in their roles. Or you could
open by establishing a common belief,
something like most people believe
success comes from those who work hard
and stay patient. So the goal here isn't
to open with one of these cliched hooks.
It's to establish common ground and to
get your reader nodding along. Next, you
want to state that idea clearly. Don't
overexlain it. You can do this later if
your reader needs more context, but your
only goal here is to get them thinking,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know that." Here,
you're setting up common ground just so
that you can challenge it. And third,
what you want to do is set up the
contrast. So, whatever shared context
you choose, think of it as the setup for
a butt or a however, because whatever it
is you establish in the status quo,
that's what you're going to flip on its
head. So, make sure that it's something
that deserves to be challenged. All
right. So, now that you've got your
reader nodding along with the status
quo, they're comfortable. They think
that they know where everything is
going. Bam, surprise. You've been one
step ahead of them all along, and now
you're going to make them uncomfortable.
That's what a good problem statement
does. It points to the instability of
what seemed stable, and it shows your
reader the cost of staying where they
are. So going again to our high agency
example, a problem statement could be
something like this. But a trend called
low agency thinking is now spreading
through workplaces and communities.
People with low agency don't just
hesitate, they actively avoid taking
action even when they could easily solve
their own problems. Consequently, they
miss opportunities, stall their careers,
and regret their earlier choices. And
it's not just hurting individuals, it's
slowing down entire organizations. So
this shift is taking us from yeah some
people are passive to this is actively
costing individuals and organizations
something precious. That's a problem.
And problems have two parts that you
need to nail. The first part is the
condition where we show the reader
what's actually wrong or unstable. And
here for our example I've signaled it
with the word but. So here's what's
wrong with the status quo. A trend
called the low agency thinking is now
spreading through workplaces. People who
low with low agency don't just hesitate,
they actively avoid. So we've got the
description of what's wrong with the
status quo. And then we move to the
consequence or the cost of the status
quo, which is that these people miss
opportunities. They sell on their
careers. So that's for individuals. But
what about if our readers are CEOs or
entrepreneurs? Well, it's not just
hurting individuals. It's also hurting
entire organizations. So, we've called
out the reader. We've said, "Here's what
you believe. Here's what's wrong with
you believe. And here's the cost of
continuing to believe that. Here's what
here's a bad thing that will happen if
we don't fix this problem that we
established right here." Without that
cost, your reader can just shrug and
say, "So what?" A problem is only a
problem when the reader cares about it.
So there needs to be either a cost that
they don't want to pay or a benefit that
they want to attain by solving it. So
here are three steps to setting up the
problem in your introduction. First, of
course, you need to state the condition.
And a really good way to do that is with
these transition words like but or
however. Now, sometimes those words can
really be kind of overused in a passage,
but I think if you reserve it to just
this purpose of announcing the problem,
at least in your opening, that is going
to serve as a big signpost for your
reader that like here is the problem.
Second, look at that problem and pass it
through the so what test. So, in order
to do this, you need to imagine your
specific reader. And you can imagine
talking to that person and that person
then saying to you so what. So whatever
you answer to that so what that is the
consequence or the benefit that that
specific reader will care about. You
can't really announce a consequence or a
benefit without thinking about specific
readers. So you can't think about
general audiences here. You need to
think about who is the person who's
going to be reading this and what do
they care about. And third, you need to
remember to keep the condition and the
consequence very close together because
if the condition has no cost, then it's
just not a problem. Readers need to see
both before they will care enough about
your idea to keep on reading. So, at
this point in your introduction, you
have made your reader uncomfortable.
You've pointed out what's wrong with
their thinking and you've shown them
what it's costing them. So, what comes
next? Well, if you just leave them
hanging there, they're going to be
frustrated and annoyed with you. Oh,
great. Thanks for telling me that
everything I understand about the world
is wrong. Well, what am I supposed to do
about it? And at this point, there are
two common ways that introductions fail.
The first mistake is that writers will
launch into a 20inute explanation of the
background of their idea before telling
readers what it actually is. It's like
someone asking, "What time is it?" and
you responding with a full lecture on
how to build a watch. And the second
mistake that writers will make is that
they leave the solution vague. So you
say something like, "We need to think
differently about this." Well, all
right, of course, but how? What
specifically should I do or what should
I think? In other words, your reader
needs to know immediately what you're
offering. Now, not all the details, but
just the promise and a general sense of
the direction that you're going in. So,
going back to George's high agency
essay, here's what a solution preview
might look like. High agency isn't
something you're born with. It can be
developed. All it takes is to recognize
specific patterns and to practice small
behaviors that compound over time. This
essay will show you exactly what those
patterns are and how to start building
them today. Now, of course, I don't
think what I've written here is
perfectly polished. You could do a lot
with this, but what I want you to focus
on are the functions here. Look at what
this part of the introduction does. It
says there's a solution. It's achievable
and it's not about changing your
personality. And I'm going to give you
actionable steps. So now the reader
knows where you're going to take them
and they can decide whether they want to
join you for the ride. So this part of
the introduction is called the solution.
It answers the problem that you've set
up earlier in the introduction. So state
it clearly so that readers know exactly
where you're going to take them. And
really there are two kinds of solutions
depending on what kind of a problem that
you're dealing with. So a practical
problem involves actions and behaviors.
The solution to a practical problem
tells readers what they should do. But
if your idea involves not what people
should do, but something more conceptual
like what we don't know and what we
don't understand, something like what
causes low agency, well, your solution
isn't going to provide them action
steps, it's going to provide them
understanding. In other words, someone
needs to change what they think. And so,
here's the three-part formula for
introductions that actually make readers
care. The first part is the status quo
which is a brief introduction to
something that is widely accepted to be
true. Then there is the problem which is
made of two pieces, a condition and a
consequence. And then only then is the
reader ready to accept your idea as the
solution to a problem that they care
about. Now, as an option, you can also
open your essay with what's called a
prelude. So that could be a statistic,
an anecdote, a quote, or even a meme. In
George Mac's essay, he uses memes a lot
to get the idea across. And I think a
tastefully chosen meme for an internet
essay is a nice touch. But if your
problem is good enough, then you really
don't need a prelude. The problem itself
should be interesting on its own. And
this is something that doesn't get
taught enough in the world of
non-fiction. Readers don't care about
topics. They care about problems and
solutions, but fiction writers, they
know this by heart. So, watch this video
next because it's going to show you how
a Pulitzer Prizewinning writer helped
turn his friend who was an unknown
researcher into a thought leader who got
published in the Harvard Business
Review. And that article is still one of
their most widely read articles of all
time. So, be sure to go check it out.